next up we have some news about the
pokemon brilliant diamond and pokemon
shining pearl games
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
release of pokemon brilliant diamond and
pokemon shining pearl is now just three
months away
let's review the main points of these
revitalized games
after 15 years pokemon diamond and
pokemon pearl have been reborn
into pokemon brilliant diamond and
pokemon shining pearl
[Music]
this adventure takes place in the sinnoh
region of land rich in nature with
towering mount coronet at its heart
as the protagonist you'll adventure
across the region catching wild pokemon
and making new friends as you strive to
complete your pokedex
along with your partner pokemon you'll
overcome the gym leaders of each area
and aim to become the champion
you'll also encounter traces of the
sinnoh region's myths passed down
through the generations and unravel the
truth behind their mysteries
this is professor rowan who entrusts you
with a pokemon he's a famous professor
researching pokemon evolution
this is your childhood friend and rival
he hones his skills as a pokemon trainer
through your friendly rivalry
rorke is one of the gym leaders you'll
take on during your journey he uses rock
type pokemon
everywhere you look team galactic is up
to something there appears to be some
sort of lofty goal behind all their
audacious activity
cynthia is investigating myths about
pokemon she's a mysterious person who
shows up at many points along your
journey
gameplay features from pokemon diamond
and pokemon pearl have been revamped and
powered up for these new
games in the grand underground you can
participate in a number of activities
such as digging up fossils or creating
your own secret base and decorating it
with pokemon statues
there are also places down there called
pokemon hideaways which didn't exist in
pokemon diamond and pokemon pearl
apparently the pokemon that appear in
the pokemon hideaways will change
depending on which statues you have
placed in your secret base it seems that
some of the pokemon living in the sino
region can only be found in this place
so be sure to fully explore the grand
underground spread out beneath the
surface of cinno
you can use the stickers you'll collect
on your adventure to customize the
effects that appear when pokemon spring
out of pokeballs such as confetti or
fireworks by collecting stickers at
various locations along your journey and
decorating with them you can make your
pokemon battles even more fun
one new feature that was not available
in pokemon diamond in pokemon pearl is
the ability to change your outfit
wear your favorite styles on your
adventure
in super contest shows your pokemon can
dance to the rhythm of the music proudly
show off a contest move and aim for a
successful show
cooperate with your partner pokemon to
really work up the crowd
[Music]
in the union room this release allows
you to use not only local communication
but also online communication to
interact with trainers all over the
world in real time
please enjoy battles and pokemon trades
with many other trainers
you can walk around with any of the
pokemon that appear in these games enjoy
your journey through sinnoh together
with your partner pokemon
encounters with all kinds of people and
pokemon and the mystery behind sinnoh's
myths await you
we hope you look forward to starting an
exciting adventure with new gameplay
features in the sino region
[Music]
you